DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hi.
I'm Dustin Kirkland,
product manager at Google,
and I'm here with my
colleague, JD Velasquez,
product manager at
Google for Stackdriver.
He's going to tell us about
the exciting announcement
from earlier today.
JD VELASQUEZ: So
we just announced
the beta release of Stackdriver
Kubernetes Monitoring,
monitoring which provides rich
and comprehensive observability
of your Kubernetes environment,
simplifying operations
for both developers
and operators.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
That's interesting.
So Stackdriver is a GKE-specific
monitoring solution?
JD VELASQUEZ: Oh no.
This is actually one
of the great things
about this announcement
and solution.
It is pre-integrated with
Google Kubernetes Engine,
but it can be configured with
any Kubernetes deployments,
no matter where they are.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Any Kubernetes
deployment, that's interesting.
JD VELASQUEZ: On other
cloud providers, or on prem.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now how does
this tie back to my Prometheus,
for instance?
JD VELASQUEZ: Great question.
So the Stackdrive Kubernetes
Monitoring solution
integrates and works very
well with open source.
We have an integration
with Prometheus.
So if you have your
application configured,
an instrument to
be Prometheus, you
can bring that into Stackdriver
without modification.
So now you have a
single place where
you can have a unified solution
with metrics, logs, events,
and metadata, by your Kubernetes
environment, including
application and metrics,
as well as custom metrics,
into a single place, to give
you that rich observability.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And how
difficult is it to turn on?
If I want to start
monitoring, I want Stackdriver
monitoring my existing cluster?
What does that
experience look like?
JD VELASQUEZ: Right,
it's very easy.
It's-- you get that
observability right from
the box.
As soon as you have a--
your Kubernetes
deployment, you're
just going to enable
monitoring, Stackdriver, done.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Cool.
And what about the chattiness?
How chatty is Stackdriver?
There's a lot of
data to be logged.
How does that work?
JD VELASQUEZ: There's
a lot of data,
but that's the
important aspect of it.
So this unified
solution will get
logs out of your Kubernetes
environment, metrics as well,
and events.
But we give them in
the right context.
So, for instance, if
you're a developer,
you want to get that data to
understand the normal behavior
of your application, right?
And to do analysis and
diagnosis when things go wrong.
If you're an operator,
you can use that same data
in a different view
in the right context.
So you monitor multiple
clusters in the single place,
and no matter if you have
an infrastructure view,
you want to look at your
clusters and your nodes
specifically, or you
really want to take a look
at your workloads
and appointments,
or even at your
coordinated services.
So all of this is integrated
in the right place.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Cool.
And can I catch events
and actually take actions
based on those events?
Maybe scale up, scale
down, spin another cluster?
JD VELASQUEZ: Right, so at
the moment with the beta,
we're surfacing events
based on incidents.
And incidents are violations
of alerting policies
that you may have.
And so, but they're correlated,
so you have an event timeline
that you can show if
there was an incident,
then you can correlate it with
the state of your company's
environment to more
easily get to the root
cause of any of these issues.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
those policies, can I
define my own policies?
JD VELASQUEZ: Right.
That's a great thing with
Stackdriver and the Kubernetes
Monitoring Solution
that we just announced,
is that it works
great standalone,
but it works even
better when you're
integrating with the rest
of the Stackdriver products.
So, for instance, you have
powerful and comprehensive
learning system, with
Stackdriver monitoring,
where you can then pursue
a hypothesis if you're
trying to root cause
an issue and deep dive
into logs in
Stackdriver Logging.
Or, even go beyond,
and try to see
latency analysis with
Stackdriver Trace,
or consumption of your resources
with Stackdriver Profiler.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And
what about BigQuery?
Can I tie all this back
to BigQuery, perhaps?
JD VELASQUEZ: Yes, so in
the Stackdriver Logging
has already exports that you can
make to BigQuery Google Cloud
Storage and Pub/Sub.
And so usually, many of our
customers take those logs,
export them to BigQuery, and do
a deeper analysis on BigQuery.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Interesting.
Do you have a demo?
Maybe you could show us a
little bit about how this works?
JD VELASQUEZ: I do.
Let me show you that.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All right.
JD VELASQUEZ: So this is
the Stackdriver Community's
monitoring console.
And what you have here is
an integration of events
and various signals
metrics, logs,
and so forth in a single place.
So the event timeline
shows incidents
that may have happened,
and if you're an operator,
you would look at perhaps
the infrastructure.
So you would go from your
cluster to your node,
and so forth.
If you were a
developer, you may be
more interested in your
workloads and deployments.
And so, you can go
from your clusters
to name spaces, and
pods, and containers.
Or, perhaps you go to
your services from cluster
to name spaces,
pods, and containers.
Once you're interested
in something,
you can inspect the
company's object further.
So I'm looking here at
a particular container.
and I'll see key metrics and
all the logs that are associated
with that container.
Stackdriver
Communities Monitoring
works great standalone,
but it works better
with all the other
Stackdriver products.
So here, I'm showing you
how you can use the Metrics
Explorer in
Stackdriver Monitoring
to further inspect any of
your company's objects.
So I'm looking at a pod, and
I'm going deeper into try
to understand this metric
of bytes transmitted.
I can change the type of
graph that I have from aligned
to a stacked area, or to a bar.
And then I can filter
down by metadata
that may be user-generated
or from the Kubernetes
environment.
So I'm filtering down
here to my service,
and then I can further group
down into whatever I want.
So there's a very simple and
intuitive, interactive way
of inspecting your
Kubernetes options.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So
that's a great demo,
and a really elegant interface.
I can tell a lot of work went
into the UX in this interface.
What can you tell us at
this point about the pricing
for Stackdriver?
JD VELASQUEZ: Oh, so
Stackdriver Companies Monitoring
follows the same pricing that we
just announced for Stackdriver,
and we have several principles
in defining this pricing.
First one is to make it
as simple as possible,
so it's very easy
for our customers
to estimate what they use, and
forecast their spend and usage.
Second, it's a
pay-as-you-go model.
So depending on what metrics you
ingest into Stackdriver, what
logs you ingest
into Stackdriver,
or the traces you
have, then you have--
you get automatic
discounts based on volume.
So all of this is following
that same simple model.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's great.
Well thank you.
I hope you enjoy KubeCon.
Thank you, Dustin.
Thank you, JD.